[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with bestselling author Dr
John deloney and man I'm getting over
something but my voice sounds terrible
now that I'm hearing it in my ears
sounds all like Smokey and sultry like
hey everybody welcome to the world
headquarters of Ramy Solutions it's
winter it's winter I blame the weather
well it is a free call and as Ken
Coleman would say a toll free call
anywhere in the country he's 141 8825
5225 give us a call we'll talk about
your money your relationships your work
and your life all right first up we have
Stacy in Atlanta hey Stacy welcome to
the show
hi Rachel hi Dr John perfect pair for
this question y um my mother recently
passed away from dementia I'm sorry and
um when my brother and I um sell her
house I'll come into some
inheritance um and all during this
process of us caring for her financially
and you know supporting her through her
health trying to keep her out of a
memory care and you know all that um I
swore to myself if there's any money
left at the end of this I'm buying
long-term care insurance so that my kids
don't have to go through this yes yes um
so
um but I keep questioning myself because
we my husband and I am 59 he's 60 um we
have not paid off our house but we're
set everywhere else so we're baby step
six um you know um so I don't know if
you want some numbers
um what's your what's your main question
because you're you're on the right track
because what you're saying you guys want
long-term care insurance which is
something when you're 60 that
weend or apply it to paying down the
house the mortgage here's where like
here's where I would suggest to go
forward two things one is go forward
with the with the the insurance two
you're entering into a window right the
longer you wait now the more expensive
it gets right and so there's it's
already going to be expensive um I'll
tell you one of if not the greatest gift
my parents ever gave me through my whole
childhood um after I was going into all
these homes with the police department
and dealing with death notifications and
taking care of people who had just been
widowed um I remember calling my dad and
saying man this is really like Weighing
on me do you all have a plan right and
we kind of talked through and he did but
for Christmas that year they got all of
us kids they got themselves long-term
care insurance and I remember exhaling
in a way that I didn't realize I was
holding my
breath cuz in the back of my mind I'd
always been thinking well if something
happens to Mom we're going to like and I
I didn't realize I was doing that but I
was and when they said hey Merry
Christmas this stuff's expensive so we
didn't really get y'all anything other
than this and a couple of books I just
went and so I would tell you on behalf
of everybody um I think it's a wise
decision yeah and it's not part of the
baby step Stacy but we do look at
insurance as one of these foundational
principles like if you were you know a
young couple with little kids we'd say
you need life insurance right and sayy
if anyone's dependent upon your income
you guys still need life insurance which
is different in long-term care so these
kinds of things that you have in your
life that are part of your financial
picture is regardless of baby steps so I
really do think yeah at your age this is
regardless if on your even if you're on
baby step two I would say this is still
something to look into because to John's
point it's only going to get more
expensive
and if something does happen it's
insurance it's there to catch those
those really expensive costs uh that
hopefully are not anytime soon um but
long term but I would yes I would go
ahead and do that and then also for your
house how much do you guys owe on the
house
250,000 okay and how much do you guys
make um about 210 okay that's great and
no and do you have any do you have kids
at home at all or are they all grown and
gone no yeah they're grown and gone okay
that's great when you sell this house
when you sell your mom's house what kind
of inheritance are you are you going to
bring home after you split it with
everybody about 100,000 that's great
okay so on an income of 210 um and you
take that 100,000 and apply it to your
mortgage because I can't think of
something I would rather my kids have
than a paid for home when I go like a
place they can always call home that
nobody can take from them that would
that would I would love for my children
to use that as an their inheritance for
that um and so so that would drop your
mortgage your principal down to $150,000
you make 210 you could knock that out in
a couple years and it should be done
have you priced out Stacey your
long-term care because you keep talking
about how expensive it is and I'm just
curious your health situation or what
numbers you're pulling I talked to um my
financial advisor and he was saying it's
about $50,000 a person um for about
$500,000 worth of um long-term care
insurance so that takes it all are you
talking about you're talking about
buying a whole life policy that's one of
those hybrid policies don't do that
please don't do that no no no no so it
what you're pricing out is extremely
expensive because they're putting you
into yeah a whole life type of insurance
don't do that don't do that don't do
that yeah you don't need to do that so
what I would do is I would look up it's
Z I think Xander does carry long-term
care insurance if they don't they'll
direct you in the right place yeah go to
zander.com Stacy because that's a
terrible Financial product of what your
financial advisor is trying to get you
in and if you guys don't have people
dependent on your income you don't even
need life insurance and whole life
insurance yes they do all these scams
within it and these like Investments and
this and that and that they try to sell
products within it and it just ends up
costing extreme a lot which long-term
care insurance it's not it's not
inexpensive but it shouldn't be that
expensive and especially upfront they're
asking you to pay for the whole policy
so Stacy look at options and again go to
zander.com um and call them yeah if I'm
pretty sure they do have long-term care
it may just be term line right now but
um talk to them because they're a
trusted people that are in this
insurance world and they know all of
this stuff but yeah go ahead and get a
second opinion and maybe even a third
opinion right shop this please please
don't buy a whole life policy please
please please please not good um and I
just Rachel that feels like a snaky
thing from her financial advisor I know
yeah yeah yeah it feels gross to me that
they're going to sell you on an
expensive product when you went um yeah
it just feels gross feels gross gross
gross gross and the whole thing about
whole life staty you have to understand
because a lot of there are financial
advisers out there that sell these kind
of products and
either them themselves know that they're
getting a great backend and so they're
just like Hey we're going to kind of
push this product because we're making
something off of it or some of them are
just ignorant some of them literally
have been sold this bag of goods too and
they believe that this is the best thing
but when you run the numbers and you
actually look at the options Stacy it's
terrible like it is and so stay away
from any anything universal life whole
life all of it because they do they try
to they try to tack on all these
different types of insurance and it
becomes extremely expensive and if you
had invested part of that money right if
you went and did long-term care
insurance with someone else it's just
purely long-term care there's no
insurance uh whole life parts of that
there's no package and yeah and you
invested the remaining part how much
you're going to have left too Stacy for
your kids right so so there's so many
different options go ahead and price
that out but do not I would not go with
that product at all um and you don't
even need life insurance at this point
if if you and your husband if there's
people not dependent upon your income
and there's enough for like burial costs
and all that like you do want to look at
at that process but Stacy also why while
you're at it you you and your husband
call one of our smart bester Pros cuz I
want you to get second opinion on your
the person taking care of walking
alongside you with your retirement cuz I
don't know that you're getting the best
[Music]
advice
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and we are taking your
calls next up we have Mia in Boston hi
Mia welcome to the show hi thanks for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help so I'm on baby step to with my
husband and our car broke so we're
stacking cash to replace it and we're in
the suck and last month I busted my butt
to earn about $3,000 on SP gigs to the
intent was to cover a small Christmas
budget and pay off debt which then got
transitioned to stack in cash for the
car replacement after repairs and a cut
and hours of my husband's job we only
ended up paying $1,000 towards the car
after replacing the emergency fund so
side gig hours are reduced this month
and the budget shows we're doing every
dollar we do a budget every month uh
since July when we started this and it
we have about $200 left in the budget
this month and it's so early in the
month and I'm really worried that we
won't have enough money to even finish
the month and U my husband thinks I'm
just being pessimistic and so I'm just
calling to see like is this normal like
to have this much of a
setback um so yes I would say for sure
and that's part of this I mean you guys
are six months in to this how much have
you paid off so
far we've paid off about 16,000 I think
good for you guys how much you have
left um over 30 okay no you're great
you're doing awesome and how much you
guys make a
year about 140 okay good for you guys
and doing some side hustle stuff yeah so
me I feel like one of the frustrating
Parts I can think of just life right but
especially if you're on a really intense
plan like this is that you wish life was
just a gradual you know line upward but
it's not it is a up and down up and down
it almost looks like the stock market
when you look at that chart right I mean
the life just happens and the great
thing about you guys though is that
you've had a plan I mean before this if
life happened you would probably had no
savings you had debt I mean all of this
right maybe living paycheck to paycheck
and so I think the positive end of this
is that even though it feels like oh my
gosh it's a step backwards it's going to
feel like that because it is
but that doesn't mean that it has to
continue like that and it won't even
though these are the times that it can
be so discouraging but that is life and
we see that all the time yeah people
call in I mean this is this is I'm like
you're you're going to go through life
people deal with health issues they deal
with job changes and losses and moves
and expenses all the time that they were
not expecting and that's so common it's
so common but when something like a car
breaks down I get it it's like it is so
it's so discouraging CU it feels like
all your hard work went to a stupid car
and you're just like like oh my gosh we
want to pay this debt down so I I I hear
you I want to say that that is so normal
even though it sucks like that's not fun
and the $200 buffer I mean I get it
because $200 can just go like that right
I'm like it's it doesn't feel like a lot
after a while but but I would say if you
guys stick to it and maybe you pull back
from Christmas even more in the season
um and do a couple of things there I I
think you're going to be okay but I
think your fear and concern
is valid so your husband's saying that
you're being a pessimist I don't think
so I think there's a level of a realist
of like things could happen and this
$200 could just be gone in an instance
but I also think that you guys are
planned and you know what's going on and
that's going to give you more Direction
and more confidence than probably you're
giving it credit
for okay yeah I mean he's he's wise but
it's just it just feels like we're not
getting anywhere and he keeps saying
like it's just two years it's just two
years and we're only six months in and
it it just feels like we're not like we
were so close to paying off our next
debt which was our last car loan and now
you know and he said the difference is
is that the old us would have just
driven to the dealership and taken out
another loan exactly right and the new
us is going to drive this crappy car
which is on its last legs and just work
harder and try to save the money yep but
I'm so tired I've worked so much extra
time and it was just so disheartening to
like I worked I basically didn't even
have like a day off for almost 30 days
and I thought I was be pulling in
$33,000 and instead it's like a th000 so
all that for $1,000 it's so
disheartening but it wasn't it wasn't
just for
$1,000 you saved your family from going
back over the
cliff
yeah like I'm gonna this is gonna sound
crazy do would it be weird for somebody
in your house to say the phrase hell
yeah no okay you're like no no I want
you to make like a hell yeah journal and
it's kind of a gratitude journal on
steroids
CU as you're working through this you
earned $3,000 on top of your regular job
this
month and you my friend kept your family
from sliding back into a deeper hole
than you even started from cuz you're
right y'all would have gone to get a car
loan and you would have got something
nice and while you were there there
would have been running an end of your
special and you would have ended up
getting way deeper in the hole than you
even started this whole thing
with and so I want you to like you saved
your life
like you saved your you did it like you
did the plan you did yeah this is the
plan you did it yes yes yeah so I want
even though it goes to something stupid
like a car cuz the car broke right like
I get it like I get it it's frustrating
so I want you to write these things down
on a regular basis like dude I worked I
didn't have a day off for 30 days hell
yeah I earned $3,000 on top of my
paycheck that goes in the journal and
that way when you have these setbacks
and you know what I hate to like be
Debbie Downer your refrigerator is going
to go out in the next 6 months I I just
promise you it will I promise and but
you'll have continueed to work and work
and work let me ask you a hard question
y'all make 140
Grand what is it about your expense
ratio cuz that's a really good salary
what is it about your expenses going out
the door that you can barely breathe
like that because your debt $3,000
that's not an astronomical ratio do you
have really expensive cars or a really
expensive home no we we went into debt
um because we had four kids EMB braces
um medically necessary so really
expensive not covered by insurance so we
went into debt last year and you know
then adopted this program got on a
budget and just like you guys said
getting on a budget like suddenly we had
a read and we had money to start paying
down the debt which is why we've been
able to pay down the debt in the past
few months we know our our cars are all
over 10 years old um you know we have a
really low mortgage payment it's just
this I have five kids and they eat a lot
and
that's a lot lot coming in and out
excellent okay I I totally get that man
kids yes they will eat eat everything
all things and then more so um I know it
sounds so trite but don't just hang in
there celebrate where you are and I know
you're like G and with five kids $200
feels like somebody could sneeze and
you're going to spend $200 I mean $200 I
get that um I would lean on my husband's
optimism in this season and then keep
keep grinding away at it keep grinding
away I'll tell you this on the back end
you are providing your
kids
lifechanging uh a life-changing picture
of what hard work looks like what
Breaking Chains looks like what changing
your family tree looks like when things
that are hard come up in their life
which they will economic problems War
relationship issues what their own
Financial issues they will have a
crystal clear picture of the time Mom
and Dad didn't even get each other
something for Christmas because they had
something bigger in mind that was
changing their family tree they will
remember that the the months mom worked
every day of the week and missed recital
and missed games and made us cook our
own dinner because she was so focused on
setting the family free none of your
efforts are lost it's disappointing that
you didn't put 3,000 bucks down you only
got 1,000 bucks down but man you are
changing everything I'm proud of you
proud of you yeah no absolutely and I
think that's a fear from a lot of
parents is oh my God I'm going to miss
out on this time with my kids like if
we're doing this for 18 months even you
saying I'm missing recitals and and
practices and all the things because I'm
sacrificing to get us in a position
where we can actually breathe as a
family um a lot of people see that as
complete detriment but it's not it's the
O it's there could not be a better
lesson I promise you if you had to have
to decide well my kids's got a travel
travel soccer game that I just have to
go to or hey son I'm going to sit down
we're going to have breakfast together
at the house we're going to have cereal
cuz that's what we're eating right now
we're going to have oatmeal um I'm
working really hard to get our family
out of debt and so I'm going to miss
this game I'm going to be thinking about
you I want you to call me the moment you
walk off that field but I also want you
to know your daddy or your mom is
working really hard to set this family
free yeah and and I would say this too
it's not in the vein of like I'm a
workaholic and I'm just going to work
and work and work till the day is long
there's a plan there's a time set and
there's a goal a very Noble goal in the
midst of all of that so remember that
parents this is the ramsy show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this this hour with
Dr John delone we are taking your calls
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at
88255 225 you know Christmas you guys it
is right around the corner and John I've
done so many interviews recently for
different media Outlets talking about
budgeting and Christmas and everyone's
shopping and feeling like they're over
their budgets and going into debt and
it's insane so you guys remember as
you're shopping be wise don't put
yourself in a financial hole I mean
there was I saw a study 25% of Americans
are still paying for Christmas from last
year so don't be one of those people be
on a budget be wise and as you're
shopping we have some great affordable
gifts gifts that can actually help the
people in your life help your friends
help your family there's so many
meaningful gifts that are only $112 at
Ramsey Solutions we're continuing our
Christmas sale only $112 so The Total
Money Makeover baby steps millionaires
own your past change your future all for
just $12 and even your questions for
humans John it's back for $10 so if you
need some great gifts that are in your
budget that are inexpensive but actually
are great gifts go to Ramy solutions.com
store hey can I can I add something to
that so this is me being a little bit
vulnerable talking about stuff I don't
usually talk about on the show usually
keep this stuff private but here we go
um I think it was last year when own
your past change your future came out
right and um it was a number one
bestseller did well yeah so I grew up
the son of a police officer and a
minister and my wife grew up the
daughter of two teachers and then we had
number one best-selling book money which
was something we'd never
experience and I had seen an escalation
in our kids
Christmas and me continuing to try to
show them how much I love them by how
much stuff I bought and last year was a
mad house I I overid it I went bananas
yeah and this year in preparation Sheila
said way early we we have to be
responsible and so my son and I we go to
I talk about this we go to breakfast
every week and he's 13 and about a month
and a half ago during breakfast I said
listen um Christmas is going to look
different this year the last few years I
just keep buying more and more stuff
more and more stuff you and your sister
you'll have enough stuff we're going to
buy a couple of things that are
important we think maybe one or two nice
things and we're going to give a lot of
stuff away
and we're just going to spend time
together having some adventure and my
son's response he got quiet and he said
dad I don't think you can do it uhuh and
here's what he was saying Hank raised
the bar Hank was not saying are you
serious you're not going to get us a
bunch he said he was expressing I know
Dad it's
overwhelming but I think you buy gifts
for us for you and so I tell everybody
that for this my kid's not I mean he's
special and he's my son he's the
smartest kid and best looking kid all
that stuff
that's not the point the point is if
you'll sit down and have a direct honest
conversation with your kids about the
state of of your your financial life in
your home y like our last caller we lost
we got hours cut we're trying to get a
debt fill in the blank if you'll be
honest with them and say Here's what
we're going to do they're with you you
know why because they feel the tension
in their home they know something's not
right and if you say hey this is going
to be a different kind of Christmas you
and your sister you and your brother you
all five of your brothers and sisters
you'reall going to get three gifts this
year that's what we're going to do and
they're not going to be big and I just
want you to know ahead of time we have a
plan but we're going to do some
different things this year we're going
to go hang out we're going to play have
that conversation with your kids and I'm
telling you they're going to respond in
a positive way yes I'm telling you well
and it sounds so silly because it's so
simple but John I'm like we over
Thanksgiving like we took the kids we
went and got bik our B all the bikes
went to an empty parking lot at high
school nearby and we just they just
literally rode bikes in this big empty
parking lot for like probably 2 hours we
went on a hike the next day like we just
did so much stuff with them activity
wise and then we go and clean out the
playroom closet and they like oh that's
good that's good but all they can talk
about is riding bikes in the parking lot
do you know what I mean so I'm like we
all know this but yet we get sucked into
this consumerism and this Christmas and
and the Amazon big you know uh catalog
they send and the kids are looking
through it I want this and I want you
know and you just get caught up in it
when you just stop and be like want oh
my gosh yes want want time with their
parents just crap that we buy crap that
80 pieces and you're just like oh my god
get all of it away get all of it away
it's all these like little things how
many people have you talked to who went
to Disney World with their kid and all
their kid comes back talking about was
the hotel pool right just your kids want
you they want you they want you they
want you so have the conversation if
your finances are tight this year and if
your fin finances are not tight this
year like you have to spend don't use
Christmas as a way to to to sing and
dance in front of your kids like like
they don't want your song and dance they
want you want you that's right all right
let's go to the phones we got Kelsey in
Austin Texas hey Kelsey welcome to the
show hey y'all Merry Christmas and thank
you for taking my call how are you guys
Merry Christmas Kelsey I don't think
I've said that yet on the show and that
was a good Texas hey y'all that was
awesome thank you guys so much so my
question is my husband and I are in baby
step two and we have a really great
opportunity to move back home to North
Carolina and start the process of taking
over um a 100y old family
business but we are about like we'll be
lucky if we break even on our house here
um just outside of Austin and so really
my question is do we wait until we have
more equity in our home to move or do we
um kind of take that opportunity and
like try to just break even with our
house here yeah I I wouldn't wait I was
gonna say I've bought and sold multiple
houses in my life Kelsey and one of
those times because the economic
incentive on the back end was so
important um I ended up having to take a
check to closing I lost I technically
lost money on my house okay not a lot it
was a little bit it was like 4,000 bucks
that was the check I had to take to
closing which sounds bananas but the
following year my wife and I paid off
six figures of debt and so the trade was
definitely worth it yes yeah so the
trade-off for sure for you guys and
Kelsey you guys are on baby step too so
when you move back home I would rent
don't buy again rents while you guys get
out of debt how much debt do you guys
have left to pay off um we have about
40,000 left okay and what's the what's
your income is it going to go up or down
this first year when with the new
transition of the job um it'll actually
go up for both of us um for my husband
it'll go up and then I will also get a
promotion with my my company um so good
go up yeah okay great yeah I wouldn't
let the house stop me honestly I would I
would sell it and don't try to be a
long-distance landlord and keep it and
rent it and wait for the market all of
it it's just you know we always say with
real estate whether you're buying
whether you're selling whatever it is
it's it's when is a good time for you
right you're looking at your situation
you're not trying to gauge the market
because we don't have a crystal ball we
don't know what's going on but but one
thing I do know Kelsey yeah since you
guys are on baby step two do not buy
just go in rents for you for a few years
make sure to get this this uh debt paid
off get a good fully funded emergency
fund and then put down you know save 5%
for a good down payment to five to 5 to
20% or more if you want to uh for a down
payment but I would not rush back into
Home Ownership which can be hard when
you've done it and then you feel like oh
my gosh we're going back to renting but
that's going to be the smartest Mo we
did it not well this first time and you
feel it not yeah absolutely I'm like
let's wait until we're totally ready yes
what's the business you're going back to
to take over what was that John sorry
what's the business you're going to take
over um it's actually a 100-year-old uh
Furniture business so we're really
really excited that's great whose side
of the family is it yours or his it's on
his side of the family okay okay that's
great and you're able to keep your job
when you guys move yeah yeah I'm fully
remote and it's a um Fortune 500 company
so yeah I'm able to move which is such a
blessing yeah that's have y have yall
counted the cost like to your souls and
what it's going to be like to leave the
the Lone Star
State you know we honestly we got we
came here for the military and then we
transitioned out and we love Texas um
but John why is Texas a whole country
like it's so far from everything uh you
live there you know why it is Hey listen
when I when we told people we were
moving to to Nashville like multiple
people took me out for like a drink or
for coffee like and and double checking
you're like hey is this the right move
like you're leaving the motherland you
know al-qaeda's waiting for you on the
Arkansas border they're waiting and I
was like I think we're going to be all
Texas people are so bizarre withing
States they're just proud of their home
which I guess so good for you get out of
there Kelsey Go For It Go
[Music]
vs
hey guys it's Rachel Cruise it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based Health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and taking your questions
atp8 825 5225 it's a free call anywhere
in the country up next we have Jam Jamie
in San Antonio hey Jamie welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we help if I needed a
Dream Team to help me you two are the
ones I would pick we got we are here for
you Jamie we are here for you what's up
I need you I have a very simple question
in a very messy situation um at what
point do I stop
investing um kind of what's going on I'm
45 I'm disabled and I'm freshly divorced
um so I'm on a set income and I need to
start making a budget and I'm not sure
what to do with my money um I bring in
about 4,000 a month but I only spend
about 1,500 I'm debt free and I have um
a little over $650,000 in brokerage
account 600 and what 50,000 50 good for
you Jamie okay um this is from the
divorce and okay I received probably 90%
he received maybe 10 if that okay but I
feel like I cannot make any Financial
mistakes because I cannot go out and get
a job um if anything goes wrong
um I'm scared yeah Jamie I want you to
do me a huge favor I want you to take as
deep breath as you possibly can and I
want you to hold it for a count of three
okay do it take it deep in hold it one
two
three let it
out okay I want you I want you to hear
me as directly as you can okay
financially you're in great
shape okay
okay you're in great
shape I I can hear the words but I just
can't I know you can't I know but when
you get scared in the middle of the
night I want you to hear those words
what happened in your
marriage um after 21 years I found out
um
he yeah he's he's been cheating on me
for a
[Music]
while um he's recently admitted that he
has a sex
addiction uh so it's been going on with
a lot of people huh a lot of people I
found I found out
um I couldn't I couldn't say I couldn't
no um no no no no and my my kids are
broken and I'm broken and so on paper it
looks so good and I know that because
I've been Dave Ramy since 2009 I'm
should have better than I deserve but I
am I can't I'm afraid I'm gonna make a
bad decision I'm afraid I'm going to
become a shopping addict um I I can't
eat my emotions because of I've had
bypass surgery I cannot drink alcohol I
can't smoke I I can't so I'm stuck here
having to deal with
this and I I'm I'm scared I'm I so I
have back to the question I have about
2,000 plus extra each month I have
650,000 in brokerage can I just take a
break can I just go on vacation when I
want to
or what do what do I do yeah yeah oh
Jamie um how how recent was all this
um the divorce was Final um on September
okay so my rule of thumb I always tell
people is no big big decisions for six
to six months to a year okay that that
doesn't mean don't go out with your kids
you all need to go somewhere and just be
together I um had some medical issues
and I I received we have two homes I
received both of them in the divorce I
sold the first one and I moved to 16
hours south I had to get away from him I
had to move and I have my son with me
and my daughter is in college and she
will not talk with him she won't and so
I'm constantly like the in between and
so I'm covering every bomb that he
throws and the kids just don't know what
he's doing wrong and so I'm I'm worn out
yeah but then I'm
also keep
thinking at some point I'm going to
break and is it going to be a financial
bad decision is it going to be what is
it and I have you broken before cuz you
keep mentioning have you have you lost
control
before no I think it's a control isue I
can only control my money right now
that's not true that's hold on hold on
that's not true you can't control
him but you can control you have you
have you had struggled with addiction
before have you struggled with out of
control behavior
before my brother died of addiction last
year
okay and so
I'm very um aware of slip Falls and I I
get that but is that you yeah because I
hear a very strong woman whose entire
world just blew
up yeah and and Jamie one thing JN has
said and I've heard you say this before
which I feel like is so true right now
what I'm hearing from you Jamie is that
especially when someone walks through a
situation where there's been dishonesty
broken trust infidelity like anything in
that category the the spouse on the end
questions oh my gosh can I trust myself
yeah you've lost trust in you because I
feel like I was trusting him and then he
comes up living this completely
different life how am am I the crazy one
you know like you you well that's what
he told me for years is I was the crazy
one and I made it all up and I was
manipulated for years by him so he could
cover it up yes which is
obviously the complete opposite of
what's going on so Jamie all of that you
were sitting here and second guessing
yourself on everything you know you're
second guessing yourself that you're
going to have a shopping addiction
because your brother struggled with
addiction but you haven't struggled with
addiction you're trusting yourself that
I'm going to spend all of this money
$650,000 I don't know if I can trust
myself with money you can trust yourself
with money you've been doing this stuff
since 09 of how to of how to handle
money well right so I want you again and
I don't even know how to like walk you
through that but I want to give you
confidence as a as a as a longdistance
friend that's met you for two minutes
tell you J you can trust yourself more
than you're giving yourself credit for
so just hear an outside voice say that
cuz you're questioning every part of
your life which is understandable like
hear me say that understandable but but
for someone on just the outside looking
in I just want to say that truth over
you that you can trust yourself okay
you're not crazy I want to ask you this
question yeah you like repeat that to
yourself you're not crazy um you were
married to a sociopath who put you in
extreme danger by having multiple
multiple sex partners you didn't know
about and destroyed the trust that and
and gas lit you the whole way so you're
not crazy now I'm going to ask you some
direct questions are you going to blow
all $650,000 of this
money no okay are you gonna take care of
your
kids absolutely every day okay every
second are you gonna honor and take care
of
Jamie I'm trying okay you are now you
have to have to Priority number one full
stop you have to get a couple of people
in your life
okay that will sit with you and have
coffee now that's gonna be very
difficult because you move 16 hours away
right oh yeah whether that's a a
therapist whether that's a counselor
it's a local church you have to have
people with you during this time and it
cannot be your kids they can't be the
person who the people who prop you up
right right and I would block husband I
would take him out of my phone I would
cut him off X yep X there you go yeah
thank you for catching me on that one um
and at some point point because he is
such a out of control dishonest person
he's going to at some point try to snake
his way back into his kids' lives and I
want them to have that he's already
started yep of course he has um I want
you to have that conversation with your
kids that they get to walk away from
somebody who is a sociopath
okay and that's okay because I keep
telling them like he's your dad and they
don't know everything obviously how old
are they
19 and 21 okay um there is a way to tell
the
truth without telling them that their
father is evil okay and or there there's
a way let me even let me rephrase that
even more there's a way to tell them
that their F their father has is is very
dishonest has had a pattern of
dishonesty has not told the truth put
you at extreme risk without saying your
dad sucks and he's a terrible person
right one of that is one of those is
just running somebody down the other is
just telling the truth about what
happened okay that's okay we're not
going to we're not going to disparage
but we're going to tell the truth okay
all that to say you got to get some
people in your life hang on the line and
we're going to give you three free
months of better help I want you talking
to a counselor before tomorrow is over
thank you for the call thank you Jamie
thanks to everyone in the booth thank
you John for a great hour thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with bestselling author Dr
John delone and we are taking your calls
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at
88255 225 all right up next up first
this hour we have Stephen in Springfield
Hey Stephen welcome to the show hey good
morning or good afternoon guys how are
you we're doing great how can we help so
I'm kind of in a position so uh really
just kind of looking for some advice so
my wife was involved in a car accident
about a year year and a half ago oh gosh
is she okay we're uh yeah she ended up
being okay she had some uh she almost
had to have some surgeries and
everything and it it affected her work
she's a hair stylist so she works for
herself um she had some hand injuries
and things like that so so we incurred
some medical bills and um some time off
work and everything else kind of my
question is I've got I've got a list of
our payments and what our debts are and
um we're expecting to get about
$22,700 back in a settlement um from
from that accident and I was just
wondering if you guys could could help
point me in the right direction uh what
we should maybe pay off or we should put
it in our savings account and just sit
on it and continue to make our monthly
payments like normal just kind of what
the best course of action you guys
thought would be yeah it's a good
question do you guys have any money in
savings right now very little so we
actually uh we have four kids one of our
kids is disabled so you know it's kind
of a it's a back and forth thing you
know okay so really nothing in savings
so how much what's your debt like give
me like a list of it in the amounts yeah
so um our house uh we owe about 44,600
on her house um we just incurred a new
debt which we bought had to buy her a
vehicle after the accident hers was
totaled um that we owe 21,000 on it uh
we got a pickup that I that I drive owe
17,000 on it then we've got a personal
loan for about
$2,000 and then somewhere in the the
neighborhood of5 to $5,500 in credit
card debt oh Stephen you're not going to
like what we say that's fine no that's
what I'm looking for how much do you
guys make a year Stephen about
75,000
okay
um yes
so okay can I say it before you give it
to him Rachel let me just say this
Stephen how' you find
us um I was actually just scrolling
through Facebook and and ran across some
Dave Ramsey videos and started listening
and how long ago you know oh not very um
okay probably probably three months ago
if that all right so you are like in the
in still like in the uh the entryway to
our Our Gang right yeah yeah you could
call it the infancy I guess okay so
we're I'll be super gentle and kind okay
I want you to begin to transform your
language okay from we had to I had to go
take a loan out and buy a a a $21,000
car I have to have a $177,000 truck to
yeah we we chose to do that okay yeah
okay that's going to be key as Rachel
walks through because the other when you
when you approach life as reactive life
did this so I just have to do this you
will stay broke for the rest of your
life if you say come what
may I will stand firm on a principle I
don't borrow any money outside of a
mortgage period ever and a mortgage only
if I got to now you're about changing
your entire family tree okay okay it's
about taking ownership okay all right
Rachel um Stephen how much could you get
for the 21 the $21,000 car have you
Kelly Blue booked any of these in your
truck um yeah so my my truck's actually
worth about
30,000 um in in today's market I
actually just looked it up the other day
and actually had the dealership the
dealers called me the other day offering
me 30,000 just to buy it out right from
me wow okay not interest not not
interested in doing that I mean well I
guess I could be you're going to you're
GNA get real interested you might be in
a second how about the $21,000 I could
definitely be interested in that um and
then I think my wife's van it's probably
right at Worth right at what we owe on
it okay
okay um and did you say you have $5,500
in credit card debt or500 $1 about 5500
okay and what is the credit card debt
what does that consist of what what what
were you what were you guys swiping the
credit card for you know it it really I
mean it was kind of Christmas last year
and then you know and I listened to to
part of the show earlier when you were
just talking about Christmas you're one
of the 25% Stephen yeah yeah and I was
really kind of really hit home and then
you know school closed and everything
else okay so just life okay so uh one
bright side of this Stephen to make you
be like okay you're normal you're normal
you guys literally are the Every
American Family you got two car loans
you got some credit card debt you got a
personal loan and you're just living
life but you probably feel like Stephen
oh my gosh we work really hard and I
feel like we're broke I feel like we're
barely making by how how is that
possible okay so that feeling that
you're feeling is is a flag that is
raised in your emotions to say like okay
we're not doing this correctly so the
way you guys have been looking at money
because you called in this show the way
we're going to advise you is a complete
180 of what you're of how you've been
looking at money and here's the deal too
Stephen you have to realize okay I have
to do a 180 because what I've been doing
is getting me these results and I don't
want these results I want something
different which means I my actions and
my thought process have to be completely
different now right so so what we're
going to say is probably going to
radically shake you up and you're going
to be like wait these people are
insane maybe a little but we're also not
broke so let me we do these things in
our own homes yes yes we live this stuff
out Stephen so if I woke up in Stephen's
shoes and your wife's shoes here's what
I would do I'd sell your truck today get
the $3,000 go get a $155,000 car that
debts completely gone you got a great
truck or great car whatever you have for
15K you're calling it a day uh I would
take the
$22,000 that you guys have and I would
knock out the personal loan I would
knock out the credit card debt and then
I would put anything else that's there
I'm trying to do this quick math um
anything else left at the car loan so
you guys will probably have about I
think $115,000 left on the van and I
Want You
Stephen for about a year to or no I
didn't have to be a year yeah maybe a
year to work extra I want you guys to
take on extra jobs either at your
primary job I want you to drive for Uber
Eats I want you to do the most radical
stuff to earn extra money and get this
van paid off because you could look up
in one year Stephen and your whole life
looks completely different but your so I
actually I actually just started a new
not new job a new side job if you good
okay I'm a I'm a career firefighter
that's what I do for a living okay there
just frankly there's there's no money in
that um oh Sor oh shoot Stephen sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off we're going
into a break anyways but but but all
that to say this that's that's exactly
what I would do when I laid out out for
you and it's going to feel different
it's going to feel uncomfortable it's
going to be strange but I'm telling you
Stephen this $22,000 if you guys get
this settlement and you get this cash
and you don't change anything you don't
cut up credit cards you keep living your
life it's going to be gone it's going to
be gone put it to good use put it to
good use and you guys could look up
again in a year and be in a completely
different position financially so we're
cheering you guys on thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
Stephen
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and and shipping
is always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show if you
are a new listener like Stephen from
last the last segment or an old listener
you've been with us for decades one of
the best things that you can do to help
us get the word out about this show and
get people the information that they
need to help take control of life and
their money is to share the episodes of
this show so whether it's on YouTube
whether it's on podcast it's one of the
best ways to get the word out and you
guys I mean this is I see this stuff all
the time even from my friends and family
we always will text podcasts that we're
loving and all of it so added to that
group um and and those messages that
you're sending out anyways because again
it helps us when it comes to getting
hope hope and Direction and guidance for
people all over their lives or for their
entire lives so that would be a
wonderful thing so again share the show
subscribe leave a review share with a
friend all right up next we have Michael
in Dallas Texas hey Michael welcome to
the show hey Rachel I John how's it
going doing great how can we help hey so
I have a clothing business I saw use
men's clothing on eBay and I've been
doing it for about three and a half
years and recently my wife was able to
quit her W2 job join me and we are
currently in baby step 6 and so I sort
of a two-part question here so I
constantly feel like I'm in this race to
increase my income with this business
and and whatever else it is in life and
um with that my wife and I are
considering pausing investing for three
months and sort of cutting out some
unnecessary spending uh to use that
money to put back into the business and
grow its Revenue quicker and in hopes
that our goal being to pay off our house
within three years from now and I was
just curious if there's anything wrong
with doing something like that you know
I wouldn't necessarily recommend it I
mean it's just I know it's just three
months on one end you're like we're just
pausing for three months it's not that
big of a deal and then I would look at
on that same on the other end and say
well it's just three months it's not
that big of a deal like either way right
so meaning I would I wouldn't pause it
because I don't think three months is
going to completely change change your
life and change your numbers that
drastically well my bigger concern is y
running your business out of your
checking account
what was that John my bigger concern is
you're running your business out of your
checking account oh no sir we we have a
business account we have a and then our
personal checking accounts but you're
talking about investing you're like
retirement investing is what you're
talking about pausing for three months
correct correct yes which is on the
personal end I think is what John's
saying like that that should be money
that you guys are using out of a income
that you're paying yourselves that's
where the retirement investing comes
from so you're saying to pay yourself
less yes that's what I'm saying so just
basically take home less a month
basically take home what we need to to
survive and and still enjoy life a
little yeah um but and then use the
extra money to increase the business
yeah I hear you and I just don't think I
would Michael I think it sets a
precedent that if we feel like we want
to grow really quickly we're going to
just pause and pull back I mean I feel
like you guys you don't you don't have
to do any of that you're not on fire
right like I mean like if if you guys
were about to lose your house or
something then I'd be like oh yeah I cut
everything I go this far if you told me
hey we've gotten real close in 6 months
we're going to have our house paid off
if we pause investing I would say go
knock your house out like go go get it
go get that thing done because you'll be
able to catch back up with your like
you're not going to miss that because
your house payment can then go to fund
your so knock that out this I like
Rachel I like what you just said this
feels like we're always going to have
this in the back of our head that we can
borrow from ourselves now if you want to
pay yourself Less in salary that's a
very common thing like in in your draw
from your your business but I would want
your giving and I want your Investments
to still be rolling with you does that
make sense yeah that makes sense and I
guess part of that question the first
part of that was like does that whenever
the house is paid off and this is sort
of my thoughts like whenever the house
is paid off I'm just curious does that
feeling that I have of like of just you
know feeling like you need to increase
your income and need more does that sort
of go away once you have all of those
expenses like out of your life that are
recruiting that are debt related not
necessarily because I feel like that
feeling I can speak for personal
experience is more of an emotion than a
fact like I think you guys are
go-getters I think you've started
something that's amazing I mean how much
are you making a year with this clothing
company uh right now 13,000 a month 150k
a year okay so yeah so you guys I mean
you're doing great you I mean you've
created something out of nothing and
you're doing an incredible job and so I
think that there's a natural bent
possibly to you Michael I could just be
making this up where you kind of are
hustle and I want to do the next thing
kind of bigger better we want to pause
retirement for 3 months because we want
to throw more at the business we can you
I mean like you're you're a go-getter
right you're very proactive but I think
with that same spirit and again I'm
saying this to myself it can be like
okay well once we get to here
everything's going to be fine but you're
going to get there Michael the house
going to be paid off you guys are going
to be you could double your business and
it's going to feel amazing and then in
about five months you're going to be
like okay okay let's go to the next goal
and you just keep pushing yourself and
not that goal setting and all of that is
bad but I do think there's a contentment
piece emotionally that's really
important in this and I don't know if
that's exactly what you're asking but
yes I think the weight the weight of not
yeah the weight of not owing anyone
anything and this freedom is definitely
there but there's still a rat race
inside of all of us that think and
believe if I could just make a million
right if I could make 500 million or 500
million actually that would be fantastic
I would take 500
$500,000 we'd be totally fine we'd be
set we'd be fine and then you get there
and you live in it and then you're
thinking yeah what however much money
you make you go with you right y um
here's what I would tell you here's how
my wife and I have had to adjust our
life there was a for us paying off our
house was a massive exhale
okay and as Rachel said then the old
demons about well you got to have this
and you're not enough for this and so
here was the important question we asked
oursel that changed and I'll tell you
how it changed it didn't change my go
get attitude I love working I just love
it always to be I like the pursuit I
like figuring things out I really like
solving problems for people you probably
like making money but you're also
probably like helping people get nice
clothes at a good deal right and you
like finding deals so after we stopped
running for our lives meaning we didn't
owe anybody anything my wife and I asked
a
question what kind of Life do we want to
have and what do we want that life to
feel like not like what do we want well
we want another house and more cars
that's not what we asked when you walk
in the door John what do you want this
house to feel like hey my wife when you
walk in the door what do you want the
house to feel like and what must be true
for that to happen and what that did is
it I'm still as ambitious and busy as
ever but I'm ambitious and busy about
different
things and in a weird way that I wish
I'd learned 20 years ago financially
we're doing better going after things
that make our lives more whole than idea
just running around like a maniac trying
to not be on fire
anymore right does that make sense yeah
yeah that's sort of where this question
arose from we had a talk a couple days
ago and I was sort of like where do we
want to be in three to five years from
now mind you we're 25 and 24 so we're
just trying to get for our whole lives
and so we're like well we want kids in a
few years and whatever so we sort of
wanted to just have this goal of payt
off the house early before we have kids
and get that out of the way so we sort
have this freedom to do things wouldn't
necessarily have and I think that's sort
of what you're saying but listen I want
I want you to ask a different question
cuz everybody ask the question where do
you want to be in 3 to 5 years you know
5 years
ago how different the world was three
years ago how different the world was
right so we can't control what happens
in the world one iota zero but I can
control what I want my house to feel
like when I walk in the door and when I
walk in and it's co when I walk in and
I'm a professor when I walk in I'm a
Dena student so I walk in and I'm a
YouTuber I can decide through the world
we've created what that's going to feel
like you see what I'm saying so you go
out five years what do you want this
house to feel like I want there to be a
kid and I'm pregnant with kid number two
and you're laughing and X and Y and Z
all right what has to be true well for
me to walk home laughing I can't owe
anybody any money for me to walk home
laughing we have to have like um
somebody else cutting the grass for once
you see what I'm saying we're going to
reverse engineer how we want this thing
to feel who we want to be not like how
much money are we going to have what
kind of car cuz you'll start cutting
Corners to get that money you'll start
cutting Corners to get that new car and
all of a sudden you're going to end up
with a hectic chaotic life in a bunch of
toys or you've gone on a nice vacation
or you have a pool and y'all are still
the same hustling exhausted people and I
think you guys are experiencing some
wins really early in life which is
amazing and I think what can happen is
that feeling can be so addictive where
you're like oh my gosh we got to get the
next and the next and the next and the
next and what John's saying too is
there's depth in all of that and you can
do the same action but your motivation
is different so check that motivation
and you and your wife sit down and and
have that conversation cuz it's a good
one to have thanks Michael for the call
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and our ramsy show question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly is one place that brings
together a nationwide family of locally
operated providers to help you take care
of repairs routine maintenance and Home
Improvement improvements go to
neighbor.com ramsy toay to get started
on your search all right today's
question comes from Adrienne in Georgia
Adrienne writes my fiance and I are in
our 70s ah a girl Adrian I love it and
planning on marrying in the next 6
months dude yes we're going to we're
going to end up at the end with no tread
left on the tires good for you I've
heard your advice on always combining
finances as a married couple however I'm
not sure if that's a reasonable path
when both parties have children from
previous marriages what's the best
approach here oh that's a great question
that is a great question yes yeah
because you know there yes you guys as a
as an entity as a married couple you're
going to be dealing with finances
together you're going to be doing paying
household bills like working as a team
on all of that but it always raises an
interesting point when there are grown
children involved from previous families
and you know do you suddenly combine the
family just because you got married in
your 70s and everyone's equal all of you
know what I mean like all of that and
yeah and I lean towards keeping it
separate still at this at this stage of
life I mean in my head I'm like like
your your your your immediate family
before this marriage was pretty much I
mean like you grown kids you've done
your J You' made your life this is
something different that's right exactly
this is somebody like let's just are we
going to let's just party until the
wheels fall off like let's do this
together I love that right so I'm all
about combining your incomes at this
point seeing yourselves as one because
you guys could still have 20 great years
so as much as a team aspect that you can
do sh I mean all my advice would be the
same but I would say things like a state
planning Wills stuff with grown kids if
you want to keep all of that more
separate and his money that he brought
into the marriage maybe is is divvied up
among his kid I don't know like well
this is one of the very few times and
again this this matters a lot if they
neither of them have anything it doesn't
matter right right right um but if
either of you or both of you have any
sort of um wealth or an estate this is
one of the rare times when I would be
okay not only okay but I would recommend
a prenup and here's why you're not
protecting each
other you're protecting the you're
husband or wife if one of you passes
away from cousins and kids coming out of
the woods that is going to take stuff
from you so it might be that I don't I
don't
want if um Rachel if you and I were
married and I died I don't want my kid
suing you like I don't want that mess so
I want both sides to be protected here
but I do think for the sake of your
marriage whatever money social security
coming here dividends coming here I
think they should go in the same pot and
we're going to make married decisions
about bills we're not just going to be
roommates for the next 20 years right
we're going to be married so let's do it
let's let's do it right absolutely yeah
and that's not just from the technical
aspect and the logistic side of it but
there's also an emotional part of this I
mean andrean like when you really do see
yourself as one and this is if you're 70
and getting married or 27 and getting
married there's an emotional connection
there that's really beautiful and I
don't want you guys missing out on that
even for the 20 years maybe you guys
have together um in the in the you know
vein of like well we're just adults now
and we you know we've done this all
ourselves so we're going to just keep it
separate I think you guys miss a level
of intimacy and connection if you don't
combine what yes the income that's
coming in now or Social Security all of
that like your your life livelihood and
your um day-to-day life combine all of
that financially and work as a team and
just for just just for like a different
picture of this um my wife and I have
been married for 21
years it feels like a thousand years
we've been married both good and bad
there's a chance they are married that
long or or maybe a little bit long right
that's a long time yes so let's do this
let's do it let's we're married we're
going to be married we're going to be
all in both feet in the boat we're not
just going to have one foot on land and
one foot in the water it's good all
right let's go to the phones we got Lynn
in Minneapolis hi Lynn welcome to the
show oh thank you Rachel and John I'm so
so grateful for your wisdom and can
surely use some direction in our dilemma
here oh well thank you Lynn how can we
help well we need to know how to leave a
cabin in our will to our kids without
causing resentment and
issues okay tell me about the resentment
that you think will emerge if you give
them a cool gift like a
cabin well uh they would be getting our
house as well we own our house we own
our two cars and we own our cabin
and um we are currently retired and one
of our children uh they're both in their
30s they adult kids uh one has a family
and has a really really good job and the
other one is uh coming out of prodigal
stage and um is on really good track and
is uh at the University getting a degree
um finishing a degree in cyber security
so and he's really good at computers and
Tech stuff so we're hoping the best for
him at this point but um traditionally
he doesn't have money and the cabin
costs about 25 to 30 grand a year just
to sit there and it's not a ma a fancy
cabin it was built in
58 but between property taxes and
utilities um it cost about 25 to 30
grand here so if this is given to them
and now all of a sudden you
know generally cost would be split and
they would probably split a calendar on
it as far as when they would use it and
stuff like that um you know the one
without the money is is uh I don't know
maybe the one with the money is going to
be left holding the bag to pay for
things the one without the money right I
mean I can just see this whole thing
yeah no absolutely Lynn do they both
want the
cabin oh yes they do okay so it is like
a the it's the family Jewel yes okay
okay now the one that com now the one
that doesn't have the money he's not
going to not have money
forever correct right but but that's
been his life so
far Yeah Yeah well yeah at that point
this doesn't become a gift it becomes a
burden um the point that you just they
he can't afford to be able to
participate in something because you
guys aren't leaving a million dooll fund
to be able to pull from to keep up the
cabin right they're going to be expected
to pay this $30,000 a year to maintain
the cabin and so it' be like any other
asset I think as an adult that if I
can't pay for this out of my own pocket
and help keep this afloat I can't afford
it and so I know that's really harsh I
know it's really harsh because of the
situation and and it's a family you know
part but what ends up probably going to
have to happen is uh I would I would
still keep it 50/50 and then I would
communicate all of this but the older
son there's probably a reality that he's
going to have to buy out the other half
of the brother because the other brother
can't maintain that now if he now in in
five years Lyn he could right able to
help pay 105,000 a year at this point U
our estate is probably worth around5
million so at this point he would be
getting half of that
so he could you would have some money to
be able to operate it right is is what
about the possibility of putting it into
a trust and then putting some sort of um
creating a fund that would pay for this
thing for a
decade oh
I love that the word the the language I
would use would be an endowment it
wouldn't really be like that but it
would be an investment fund that was
designed to pay for this thing for X
number of years the other thing would be
this what if you left it to your oldest
son and said in the will it is our
expectation that you share this with
your
brother yeah he'll pay for the upkeep
he'll pay for the stuff and the asset
stays in his family of course and so
that becomes like oh I want to split
whenever we sell it and I don't want
Uncle Sue and nephew kind of thing but
yeah I I'm like you I I don't know I I
just hate to put somebody in a position
where the whole I've got to put fight a
brother's got to fight a brother because
of a gift right I'd rather an
uncomfortable conversation up front hey
we're going to give this to your brother
the expectation is you'll be able to use
it whenever uh y all will navigate that
yes but if he gets out that full asset
then he is still technically owed part
that money right the brother will have
to buy him
out well we have a break this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and we are taking your
calls and your questions about your life
and your money with the giving season
upon us we do a giving show every single
year and it's coming up here in a few
weeks and so we want to hear stories
from you and how you have given
generously this season so maybe you
tipped a waiter waitress you know 100
bucks or maybe you bought a Thanksgiving
dinner for a family that couldn't afford
it whatever the creative ways that you
have been giving this season we would
love to hear about that and that story
of how it's changed you how it changed
the lives of the people that you are
giving to so if you go to Ramy
solutions.com askk and put giving in the
subject line we want to hear your story
we do this every year around this time
and this show is going to be on December
18th so start sending in your stories
today because we are all about living
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else giving and
generosity is a huge part of our message
and we love to celebrate that so again
December 18th is our giving show we want
to hear from you ramsy solutions.com
askk and put giving in the subject line
can I say something real quick about
that we do not tell giving stories so
that we Pat you on the back for giving I
think the giving stories are super
impactful and I've learned from them it
gives me a picture of what giving looks
like in the wild and it gives me ideas
because I don't it it might never have
occurred to you to tip tip you tip
somebody $500 and they start to weep
like never even occurred to me to I'm
going to try that right you just walked
into a Walmart and saw um a mom with a
thing full of groceries and you just
stuck your ATM card in her thing and
paid for it never occurred so this is
putting a like 20 different pictures of
what generosity looks like in the minds
of millions of people so this thing
spreads all over the place this is not
about patting each other on the back
being like Oh way to go dude not that at
all but it also is
like good for the soul like so good for
soul good people out yes when you just
watch the news all day and you start to
like get in this belief system that
everyone's crazy and we're all you know
and and that is the funny I'm like we
travel around to events and you know we
meet people here in the lobby all the
time and I'm like there's just great
people out in the world you guys and
doing amazing things and when we can
highlight that and encourage you uh
that's what we want to do so it's a
great Point John all right up next we
have Chrissy in Cincinnati hey Chrissy
welcome to the
show is this real life no it's real
you're dreaming Chrissy this is not real
very much feel like I am dreaming my
Fant we're glad you called hi guys hello
I cannot thank you both enough for
everything that you guys do um and um Dr
John deloney oh my gosh like my my go-to
for how to make it through the day I've
listened to every one of your podcasts
probably 75,000 different times I
haven't even listened to them at all so
good that's awesome thank you so much me
your mom and the other original
17 awesome so what's up but so uh my
question today is um I'm looking
for excuse me um take a big hey do me a
favor take a big big deep breath
Chrissy and hold it for a kind of three
one two and then let it
out okay that's better neither me and
Rachel can drive very well but you're
safe you're safe with us what's up
awesome awesome okay so um my husband
and I were um trying to get pregnant for
quite a while and um we couldn't afford
the IVF stuff so we just kept trying and
I had a Pluff of different procedures
over the last couple of years um
including have a c having a couple of
surgeries to have tumors removed um and
then in April of this year I was
scheduled for one last surgery to have
what we thought was going to be the last
of these tumors removed and that surgery
ended up being a complete hysterctomy oh
I'm so sorry Cleveland Clinic as well as
several of the local renowned hospitals
here in Cincinnati um have given me a
diagnosis of primary perianal Cirus
tumors and um basically all the organs
they took out were riddled with cancer
and it has invaded my peritoneum and um
there's there's things they can do to
help but nothing they can do to really
make it go away um and so um I am really
just trying to figure
out a way to deal with this while um
still being a parent to an 18-year-old
and being a wife and um while while
still trying to manage our family's
finances because um treatment is very
much not something that is in our budget
right now and it's um it's a kind of
it's a um it's a kind of scary scary
thing to know that um I I I can't afford
the treatments to be better and um I
just I I kind of don't know what to do
and I feel like I am at my wit and day
in and day out and um I feel like it is
affecting my ability to be a good mom to
my 18-year-old and um to be a good wife
to my husband and um grieving the fact
that we're not going to my husband and I
are not going to have a child together
and
um and also just kind of um you know I'm
only 37 and I am very much not ready to
die um but this feels like I've been
given a um like a light sentence and I
just I don't know where to go yeah will
you do me a huge favor number one well
number one thanks for being brave and
laying it all out
there I want you to take both of your
hands and I want you to squeeze them as
tight as you can for a count of three
okay where it's almost uncomfortable
squeeze them as tight as you can one two
three open them up and open them
wide
okay usually when people do that their
shoulders drop
too yeah they did okay this is a
posture this is the posture you are
entering into the next phase of your
life through your attempts to get
pregnant through your attempts to um
Wrangle an
18-year-old is this a relatively new
marriage for both of you
uh we've been together six years but
we've been married for just over two
okay you have a picture of what a quote
unquote perfect wife
is your grip on your life has gotten
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter and what you found out in an
gnarly ugly scary I wish you were here
so Rachel and I could could hug you and
let you see that we love you and care
about you that we really don't control
much anything
okay right all of those questions you
rid you rattled off I don't know about
the money I don't know about being a mom
I'm being a terrible this I'm not good
enough for that let that
go
okay yeah does your husband love
you very much so would he go to Hellen
back for
you he has a couple of times I know he
he'll continue to does that 18-year-old
love
you she does I know 18-year-old
sometimes don't know how to say it just
right but does
she she does she she's pretty good at it
so what you have is two people plus you
holding hands looking at this life that
we wanted so bad that doesn't exist
anymore it's
Ash and the path before us is a above
all other things we're going to fight
and we're going to do what we can to
stay healthy
okay yeah the second thing is we're
going to be really clear with each other
how we feel how we're doing how are you
how can I love you today how can you
love me today we're going to practice
that new way of doing life together
because we're not guaranteed anything
other than write this yeah hey Chrissy
did they give you um I'm not familiar
with that type of that type of cancer
did they give you a time frame at
all no no they haven't um they you know
they wanted to do more scans they wanted
to do um some different kinds of
treatment but um I do not have health
insurance and the the scan was like I
mean it was like a $15,000 scan so that
was supposed to happen a couple of
months ago and just hasn't yet okay okay
I want you to sit down with a hospital
social worker and I want you to ask for
is there any sort of indigent care or
support care for people who don't have
insurance they'll point you in Direction
because on life and death stuff like
this Chrissy do what you have to do
right you can worry about the money
later I know it's stressful but I want
you to do what you can to fight for your
life so hear us say that I'm so sorry
you and your husband spend some time
creating what's this week going to look
like we're going to take this week by
week for the next year okay thanks for
the call Chrissy we're so proud of you
thanks to everyone in the booth John for
a great hour thank you America for
listening and remember to take control
of your money and create a life you
[Music]
love
m live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with best-selling author Dr
John deloney and we are answering your
calls it's a free call anywhere in the
country at
8825 5225 talking about your life your
money your relationships your career
anything and everything give us a call
we're start off this hour with Maria in
Denver hi Maria welcome to the show
hello hello how can we
help um I just had a couple of questions
um so I'm doing a career change from law
enforcement to
Medicine um all right yeah so I am big
it's a big change um I started working
right at 21 um so I would I'm 23 now and
I decided to make the
change in the middle of last
year um so I'm currently working as an
office manager um in a medical setting
trying to get my clinical hours you know
working on what I need to do to apply to
med school um I am in debt from my
undergrad um and then as well as like a
car a car payment and um some credit
cards and I'm attacking it but I don't
know if my plan of attack is the most
stable or sound okay um how much how
much do you owe on all those debts we
you list them out with the
numbers um so total is about
48 um credit cards is 10 car is a little
over 15 and then the rest is student
loans okay um so for the credit cards it
was a move I took out a card and then
just moved um I know not super duper
smart but um for that I'm currently
putting a little over 500 close to 600
every month towards that um to try to
just get it paid down and be really
aggressive um my loans are on the save
plan right now so they're
deferred and then my car payment is
about $300 a month okay how much are you
making a year considering you're doing
all this schooling and
everything yeah I make 37 now I consider
doing a switch um but I take my exams
and everything for the med school
admission stuff in July okay and how
much after all of that will you
owe um so I've already paid for my exams
so I don't really have to worry about
you know still paying on those
um okay for the actual meded School
application Cycles I don't have numbers
yet because I'm again I'm still working
on my prerequisites and the exams and
everything to even try to do like do you
know what what it's going to cost you
going
forward um off the top of my head I'm G
to assume um 22500 is just kind of a a
guess an estimated guess for
applications secondaries all that kind
of stuff okay all right Maria do you
have any money
saved I have 200 in an IRA dollars okay
um I don't have an emergency fund right
now okay okay what happened at your
police
job it sounds like you just said I'm I I
literally I'm
done yeah so I was my case load was
massive um for me by myself again I was
like 21 sure um I thought that was
something I had wanted to do everyone
told me you know this is something I'll
be really good you'll you'll have a job
it'll be stable blah blah blah I wasn't
making too much more than what I'm
making now and the stress was through
the roof um my case load was again huge
so I I was I realized very quickly I
don't think I want to do this forever so
I I'm gonna give you an analogy that's
not going to be Apples to Apples and
then Rachel's going to walk you through
this um I think this is and again I'm
telling you this as someone a who loves
you and B who has sat with countless
college students and I've been I was a
graduate school Professor so I've been
in your world okay
um you made a very very quick
decision and yeah here's the here's the
analogy again it doesn't hold it's not
watertight but it's close you were
driving a car that you didn't like you
like I want to drive such and such car
and you got it and you're like I don't
like this car and you just pulled over
on the side of the road and you said I
want a Mercedes and you just started
walking to a Mercedes
dealership and I'm not saying you should
have stayed in your job we're desperate
need of extraordinary law enforcement
officials but also or professionals but
also know it's a that's a demanding
brutal job I grew up in that home those
are my friends I get it so I'm not
saying that's the thing to do but I'm
also saying man it sounds like you are
not in a place financially to Swan Dive
into med school which will be one of the
most if not the most challenging
academic Endeavor a person can enter
into it's it's tough so Rachel can help
you pull apart the numbers but you're in
a bigger mess I think than you think you
are yeah cuz I'm trying to think Maria
with your timeline I want I want what
you've done so far to be credible in the
future but I can't in good conscience
tell you to continue down this path and
go into med school eventually with money
you don't you don't have while you're
owing all of this and
so what I how old are you 23 okay and
luckily my I'm planning to actually do
the applications and stuff in 2 to three
years so that's not something I'm
wanting to do like tomorrow okay um I so
what what's your plan for the two to
three years in the
meantime yeah just kind of pay off what
I can complete PRX yeah okay okay that's
a good plan okay could you consider
going to nursing school for two years
and making exceptional money and really
digging I building yourself a pretty
remarkable foundation and then deciding
because I don't here's what I want you
to I don't want you to go through all of
this go get all the
prxs and then go through three weeks of
med school and be like oh this sucks too
you see what I'm
saying yeah yeah if there's some things
you can do and especially with your age
I mean your age is on your side right
like you have the time Big Time um to be
able to slow walk this because Maria I
think one of the best places you could
be mentally is entering to something to
John's Point med school which is one of
the most stressful environments I could
only imagine that someone walks through
where I would say what if you went and
got a job somewhere and you made 60
Grand you paid off the credit card first
which is what I would do the 10,000 I
would pay off the smallest amount of
debt to the largest so I would pay your
a $300 minimum payment on your car like
you said but I would be throwing that
extra 600 more at the credit card cut it
up get rid of it pay it off work to pay
off the uh the car loan next and then
your student loans and you work your way
down that's
$48,000 and if you can do that pay off
and live like like you're in college
Maria like you're 23 so live on nothing
try to find a great job hopefully maybe
in the medical profession if not like
something else right do doing something
because I just think if you can enter in
to med school and make those decisions
in two to three years without any debt
having some savings 3 to 6 months of
expenses saved in the bank and then
start making Financial making these
career altering decisions and financial
decisions from that place from from a
financial aspect it is way less
stressful than trying to juggle all of
this so so yeah if there's a couple
things you need to finish up here in the
next few months you can do that but then
I would pause I would go find a job I
would that pays well pay this debt off
pay this debt off and then reevaluate
med school Maria which I know is
probably not the answer you want but I
think that's the best one this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
answering your calls and up next we have
Felicia in Waco Texas hey Felicia
welcome to the
show thank you Hi how are you guys we're
doing great how can we
help so um last year I had a property
that was my primary residence me and my
husband bought uh solar through attt and
a partnership program and they promised
us that we would roughly get 13 almost
$14,000 on our uh federal tax return I
bet they did didn't they oh they sure
did and that we get the returns we pay
it in our payments stay down to uh 187
some odd change and so taxes and rolls
around we
file um come to find out you don't get
that money you get a percentage and I
believe we got like it was either just
under or just over two grand by like a
hundred bucks so clearly we did not have
almost
$14,000 um to uh pay the um deferred
portion and so now
our payment will be going up it's either
this month or next month that it takes
effect and I called the company and I
talked to them and um I told them you
know what the heck you guys said we
would get this you made promises you
can't uh keep um like I don't know what
to do I don't have $114,000 to just be
like here you go keep my payments
low yeah what what did they
say um
they um they were rude yeah to say it
nicely and basically we're like well you
you know blah blah blah it's your fault
it kind of boiled down to it's my fault
I'm
uneducated and um I did blatantly get
called an idiot oh and sound like
wonderful people do you have any of this
communication and
writing is it part of a contract you
signed or any email or text message
communication I have the contracts which
state that you get um whatever that
percentage which amounted to that almost
14,000 um that we would get it in
returns which we um were allowed to then
apply to our overall loan to keep the
payment low from that deferred portion
however once I told them hey by the way
we don't get that that's not how that
works they were like basically sucks to
suck and then told me I was an idiot
well so if you well so there's two
different things here three different
things here one don't conflate legal
matters with business matters with
idiots okay you you you're in a business
relationship with them with jerks let me
say jerks instead of idiots you're in a
business relationship with them so let's
put your emotional side they called you
an idiot like you know I'm never going
to do business with them again I will
never recommend them I'm going to call
the Better Business per whatever cool
let's put that over here okay that's
when our emotional side gets gets um
fired up and we do things that we
wouldn't possibly otherwise do or we say
things that aren't really us because
we're fired up let's put that over here
if you're holding a contract that says
based on percentage X you're going to
get
$14,000 back that you're are going to
apply to the principal it's going to
keep your payment
low then they have an obligation to meet
the the um terms of the contract if they
don't you have two choices you can walk
away or you can sue
them okay that's the point of a
contract my guess is it's going to be in
the middle somewhere that basically the
language is closer to unless unless they
put the number 14 Grand they're going to
say no no you get a percentage up to
possibly including something like that
you may be entitled to up to something
like that and then when they actually
did the calculations it was 2000 not
14 and so their salesman which are
unscrupulous said told you the highest
possible return you can make up to $5
million most of our people make $50 but
you could make up you see what I'm
saying right how much how much do you
guys owe on
these um it's somewhere in the 40s when
we did our
taxes it says in our tax paperwork it
says it it shows that full 13 almost
14,000 and we get a
percentage of that so that's the
percentage of the total loan and then we
get a percentage of that
14,000 yearly as long apparently as long
as we own the house but it's within your
payments that it just lowers
it right like when we file every year we
can get a percentage of that um 13
whatever thousand did you take let me
say this did you take the contract to
your tax
attorney yes and they said I'm sorry
this is what you're entitled
to he told us because we don't owe
taxes like we get lower
returns it basically because essentially
we're too good with our money we don't
get to get the money upfront from the
government you're not getting a big tax
return you
mean correct okay on the back end they
don't give they don't send you a big
return okay sounds like one of two
things either they ripped you
off and you need to have an attorney
look at the
contract my gut tells me they painted
you a very very very Rosy picture a
possibility that did not come true and
probably almost never comes true but
came true once or twice so that they
could tell everybody that this is what
happens and you entered into a deal with
the devil you took out a debt
payment and now it's come back to buy
you and I think I yes my gut tells me at
the end of this you're going to have to
figure out how to pay this thing
off right yeah that's that's a little
bit of my fear Felicia that and it sucks
we call it stupid tax around here of
doing something just hurts and you just
think that was so dumb yeah but there's
no there's no way out right cuz I don't
think with solar panels you can like
dismantle them and resell them on a
different Market or something right like
I think with a lot of these and we and
we get this call a lot with oh my gosh
we want to put solar panels on cuz it's
going to save X Y and Z you know like
this has kind of been part of we've
heard this discussion a lot or not a lot
enough that I mean at the end of the day
it never ends up financially being a
smart move and so I hate to say it f i
feel like you may you guys
just fell for a great sales pitch and
then as as the numbers came in and it
and it laid out in front of you the
facts just not it's not the picture they
painted like to what John said but again
if there's more legal issues and and
again getting a good attorney on your
side just to look over some of it I mean
if there if there is a case there and
you guys want to pursue legal action
because you do feel like we were lied to
in a contract that's one thing but
having somebody that from a legal
standpoint be able to go through it with
a fine tooth comb and if they're and if
they deliver the news which I'm I'm I I
I'm believing probably will be true is
that it's like yeah y'all signed up for
this the return is not what they said
it's going to be but the way the
language speaks there's something you
can really do about it and you're kind
of stuck with a bad financial decision
Felicia which hurts yeah so bad and it
sucks and it Su I wish we had better
news for you and by the way Rachel I'm a
huge yeah I live out in the woods I'm a
huge fan of solar solar panels but I'm
not going to be under any illusion that
I'm doing it to save money or that it's
somehow a different alternative
investment to
right and go into debt abely right
that's the big thing is people get
caught up in this idea oh it's going to
save here and all of this so yeah if we
take out this loan I mean a little bit
of kind of how Felicia painted I like I
feel like I've heard that verbiage that
language that idea around this specific
thing solar panels and you got you got
to just run the numbers right yeah I'm
not saying they're they're bad
necessarily but I think a lot of people
justify debt to go into them and that's
usually what we see on the show it's
very similar with student loans if you
do this there's a government program for
this and then this other thing anytime
somebody says hey there's the federal
government's going to dot dot dot just
stop and say I want to see this in
writing cuz I don't believe you we start
there oh sorry Felicia wish we had
better news this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey welcome back to the ramsy show
Rachel I want to talk about our first
ever Illustrated Kids book which I love
it my daughter loves it it's the perfect
gift for parents who don't want to spend
a jillion dollars but want to get their
kids something beautiful and something
with a positive message tell me about it
thanks John yes it's called I'm glad for
what I have and it is beautiful the
illustrations are just so cute and
here's the deal with our kids one thing
I want to teach my kids is it's okay to
have stuff stuff is not bad but if your
motivation to have stuff is to keep joy
and happiness going you're going to be
very disappointed in life and so
contentment is such a powerful principle
in our lives and for our kids and I have
an eight six and four-year-old and our
four-year-old said a few months ago is
the Amazon guy coming today Mom and I
was like oh my gosh I created these like
little monsters and so I just thought
you'll have to you you have to get this
and understand it but also John like
what's funny and you know this about
parenting most parents do I can I can
say it and and read the book and all of
it but my actions and how I live life
and how I interact with money speak way
louder so the message yes is for the
kids but I also wrote it for the parents
that at the end of the book that there's
truth that you can say okay I can settle
into something so much greater than me
and it's not stuff so it is called I'm
glad for what I have so this Christmas
I've gotten you know I've gotten more
DMS I've gotten lot of parents that
bought it so thank you parents so many
grandparents yes lots of grandparents
are buying it for the grandkids so
apprciate and I think if you're
grandparents and you grew up in an era
when you didn't have a lot you know that
you can survive with you know like what
are we doing and then finally a
beautiful message comes out in a cool
book that's like hey y'all are going to
be good so that book along with the 2024
Ramy gold planner which is a planner
that Rachel me and our great friend Jade
warshaw work together to help you line
up your faith your relationship ship and
finances through month monthly teachings
for those of you like my wife is still
an OG like likes to have a planner in
her hand that she can write in with this
awesome piece of ancient technology
called a pen or a pencil um the Rachel
Cruz wallet thank God Rachel it's
finally a Navy I know so many colors the
Navy's out but I haven't been able to
breathe until the Navy went came out so
that's in our friend George camel's
first um foray into the book world
Breaking Free from broke you can still
pre-order it he actually is not just an
Instagram hero he uses real data he
doesn't just make up stuff like most of
the people on the internet do these days
and he tackles everything from credit
card schemes to investing tracks look at
him on that cover and mortgage myths I
know he's just pushing away the lies
with all of his muscles pushing away the
lies he's going to give you confidence
to actually get yourself out of the
Matrix the nonsense that our financial
system is designed to make other people
rich and George is going to give you a
path out and then of course Jade warshaw
has a brand new quick read that uncovers
the five Lies We tend to believe about
budgeting budgeting and Rachel you and I
talk to people all the time have great
jobs great careers kids and they will
quietly say in a signing line somewhere
in a strange city hey like how do you
budget right and it's easy to roll your
eyes like oh I know millions and
millions and millions of Americans don't
know how this book is 10 bucks it's
excellent It's a play-by-play on how to
make a budget and change your life if
you know somebody in your life you you
would like to change your life for 10
bucks go to Ramy solutions.com store for
that book and all the other products
that are going to help save your
Christmas that's right all right up next
we got Juliana Juliana in Charlotte hi
welcome to the show hi thank you for
having me absolutely how can we
help so my initial question is I'm
interested to know what you guys think
about
consolidation loans for debt please
don't please please please please please
don't and and and the the why behind
that is what we have found is that debt
is a
symptom of behaviors that are going on
and if you can't control the behavior
you're going to get the same result and
I think a lot of people depend on debt
consolidation or have the belief that
it's somehow going to rescue them out of
their situation but what what what's
going to rescue them out of their
situation is actually changing their
behaviors and learning how to deal with
money and so we find that I mean almost
everybody can pay their way out of debt
they can get themselves out of debt they
don't need debt consolidation that comes
with fees and everything the one type of
debt I would be okay with you
consolidating is student loans because
usually that's not a type of debt you go
back into so if you wanted to do that
because you had a better interest rate
you know that's something we can talk
about but yeah just this idea that it's
going to sweep in and save save you
that's what a lot of people believe and
it's just it's just not the case so what
what position are you in or what's the
situation that's causing you to to think
about that so right so I see what you're
saying but that really doesn't apply
really I mean I'm not saying so here's
the situation okay um so recently um my
husband um who has a history of some
mental illness um snapped and there was
a life-threatening situation which ended
him up in in a mental institution which
she's still there now so sorry um I'm
pretty sure um because of some things
that happened on his job that he has
lost his job um but in the end from time
I work and um he is the bread winner so
all of our money would go to One account
all of our bills would just come out of
this account automatically and that's
the way we've done this for years and
years and years and now all of this debt
that we have and mostly primarily
because of his history of having having
to be in hospitals previously I've had
to go into some expensive credit card
debt personal loan debt and and hasn't
been a problem to pay these things with
his check because he was the bread
winner but now my check is not going to
do it so am I looking into a second job
yes I am however U I'm 58 years old I
have a medical condition that requires
treatments every eight weeks myself so
it's not like I can do a lot a lot of
like two and three jobs I I might can do
another part-time job plus my full-time
job and hopefully get some of this but
in the meantime the thing is what's
scaring me is all this debt is like my
right now my checking account's going in
the negative because these things are
coming out my check my bank is trying to
pay them and charge me for it you got
juli jul I want yeah I want you to
to you just got thrown you were on a
boat in the ocean and that boat just
exploded yeah I don't want want you to
keep trying to drive the boat as though
it still existed as it did before all
this
happened okay so you're going to have to
think about all the way you you've been
doing things have to be different
effective immediately yeah you want to
stop all of those automatic transfers
all automatic payment stop ASAP like
right when we get off this call I want
you to call the bank or go to the bank
and cancel all of them okay if your
husband is um the only person on the
account and
you're on it okay good so we're stopping
all automatic payments okay if these are
medical bills we're gonna not what kind
of what kind of bills are running you
into the ground so it's uh I'm about
8,000 in credit cards and $88,000 in
personal loans in
De and um they're just been set up to
come out you know automatically yeah
we're stopping that okay and in fact we
might have to get a new checking account
because I don't want any credit card
company having my checking account
number period end of story okay okay
okay yeah and you might need to tell the
bank hey they this credit card keeps
withdrawing from this account I need to
move my money to a new account and close
this one Julian oh Sor because I don't
want him to I don't want him to have
access yeah is it One credit card or
multiple credit cards that add up to
8,000 multiple how
many
um six okay so here's what I want you to
do I want you to get very detailed I
want you to list out all six credit
cards separately okay and then the
personal loan I'm assuming is just one
loan correct three three different loans
okay list those out separately okay so
you're going to have nine different
debts on a sheet of paper and I want you
to go through and figure out okay where
would I want you to mark down all the
minimum payments on all of this because
how how much do you how much do you just
bring in a year
well I get I recently started a new job
about four months ago I did have to take
a slight cut and pay but I did that
because the benefit so how much how much
how much hey let's do this let's hold
her over
30 hey Juliana we're gonna I'm going to
put you on hold because we want to
finish this call and help you out the
best we can but we got to come go to
commercial break when we come back from
the commercial break we'll pick you up
um from that call because we want to
help you the best that we can hang on
this is the ramsy
[Applause]
show
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from 2
Corinthians
5:17 therefore if anyone is in Christ
the new creation has come the old is
gone and the new is here
Max depri said we cannot become what we
want by remaining who we are or what we
are H I guess that's true we cannot
become what we want by remaining what we
are yeah I think that's 100% true yeah
but what if we're kind of okay with then
you've become what you wanted to become
good grief all right so um at in the
last segment we were talking to Juliana
from Charlotte um Juliana was um is
married to somebody who's um been
suffering from some significant mental
health challenges who ended up in an
institution and they have set up all
their Bank payments on automatic draft
so the bank is coming in and taking out
these credit card payments and personal
loan payments yeah and they're running
out of money quick and Juliana is asking
is a debt consolidation loan a good idea
so we're walking her through here's the
mechanics of what you should do first of
all was stop all the automatic payments
and since the credit card companies have
her checking account number she may have
to go to the bank and close that account
and open up a new one so that's where we
landed ourselves um Julian does that
sound about right yes all right okay and
I think we were asking you J Julian you
took a new job um but we were seeing how
much income you bring in a year um a
year is around
33,000 okay and you took that new job
why what was the what was the reasoning
for that so so um for benefits wise I
don't have to pay they pay my insurance
okay and so that was a great benefit for
me considering like I said I have
medical conditions and so it was just a
huge benefit for me and it's um a few
other extra benefits that I didn't have
with my other job so I did take a little
bit of a cut and pay and but then again
having to pay the insurance on the other
job it kind of you know it kind of
equaled out really okay so I just felt
like um they offered a a a retirement
plan um and just uh things that I wasn't
offered before and at my age those are
things you start thinking about sure
sure go ahead well so I wasna in the
meantime I didn't tell you that in the
meantime of this happening I also found
out 100% sure that my husband was having
an affair so I know that go this time
our marriage is over I'm not going to go
back into that situation I've made up my
mind okay okay so I'm going to have to
handle this on my own and I definitely
have been prayer about it but I just
don't want to make another wrong
decision sure
um I would contact once you get the oh
go Rachel go ahead with the the the the
nine debts you have in order and we're
going to add up the minimums here yes
yes so I just want you to get a handle
on just the minimums because I don't
want you getting behind but right now
Julian I think it's fair because of what
you've just walked through it's
traumatic traumatic and then you find
out your husband's been cheating so
there's a lot going on so honestly I
would okay julan if you just stay afloat
that you just can pay minimum PS I don't
want you getting behind because that's
going to create a whole other mess and
lots of stress but if you can just keep
everything afloat pay minimum payments
stay current on everything and let some
of this go ahead I just don't I don't
make enough money to pay all the
payments on my own well since since
y'all are about to go through a divorce
proceeding I would actually contact an
attorney ASAP and they may be able to
freeze these payments while they're
sorting out what's going on because he's
going to be responsible for a big chunk
of the debt as yall split up your
Estates and if he my name if he doesn't
have a job then well yeah but he's gonna
have to he's going to have to write you
a check for some equity in the house for
future earning he's gonna there's going
to be some sort of settlement here and
if his claim to claim is well I got
fired from my job I'll never be able to
work again then you'll figure out social
secur there will be a process here okay
okay okay um but I want you to call a
local attorney in your area that that
you trust maybe somebody from your local
church can help you with this and you're
going to have to be honest and you're
going to have to tell the truth and not
that you're going to lie but you're
going to have to just be vulnerable and
tell something that's going to be hard
and scary and hurtful um but I want you
to get somebody to walk with you and
give you some on the ground advice okay
okay oh I'm so sorry it's that it's a
lot I know and and walking through this
I think is going to be it is going to be
so difficult but I think on that end I
want you to make sure your your lights
your lights are on utilities are paid
food is paid house is taken care of so
we call those your four walls that's
even before debt so making sure that all
of that is there and yeah talking to an
attorney and you know and and you may
get to a point that you know you'll look
up and your income will be sufficient
enough to help pay down your portion of
the debt whatever they give you and and
also if not you know there's stuff you
know whether it's selling stuff whether
it's working just you know 8 to 10 hours
extra a week I mean the things that you
can do to get out of this because we've
seen it people do this all the time and
it's hard it's not easy but it is
possible so we really do have that
belief but you're walking through a
really hard personal uh personal thing
right now in your life and I think it's
okay to grieve that and to and to be
that but um yeah I would call an
attorney ASAP especially if you know
that that you're you're done with the
marriage I also I don't know if this is
going to be worth the the breath I'm I'm
I'm spending on it but it may be worth
calling each one of those credit cards
and letting them know my husband's been
institutionalized for a mental health
Break um for a psychiatric disorder um
we don't know when he's going to be
released but he is unable to work at
this time we I'm asking for a
forbearance or can we push this off for
6 days or some some sort of medical
something or other they may say go pound
sand but it's sure worth asking and
maybe a couple of them will say yes
we'll give you 60 days we have a special
program send us the paperwork the his
admittance paperwork or something like
that that might give you a little bit of
breathing room and here's the last thing
I'm going to tell you find a friend you
cannot navigate this by yourself call a
friend that will come over and have
coffee with you every morning or a
couple of days a week and have somebody
that you can talk to thanks for thanks
for calling Juliana all right real quick
quick let's go to Morgan in Tulsa it's
going to be a fast call Morgan I'm sorry
it's the end of the show but you've been
waiting so I want to get to you how can
we help that's okay no worries so I'm
mainly calling just for some advice um
my grandma has saved in a 529 account
for me since I was really young and I
don't have any intentions on going to
school as of right now um I am got
married young at 19 started a family
young um and my husband and I are making
around 880,000 a year
we have 33,000 in total debt and in this
529 account is around 40,000 is what I
can assume um so I don't know how to go
to her because she's very career-driven
she really wanted me to go to school she
didn't want me to start a family young
and have a baby um but that's what I've
wanted for my life I don't know how to
talk with her and say hey this money is
just sitting there it expires in 5 years
we could potentially really give our
family a boost by pay paying off our
debt and having a fully stocked
emergency fund no well
you'll if you pull out a 529 and it's
not on educational expenses you're going
to pay income tax and a 10% penalty so
with your income I mean it's going to be
around
305% um out of this 40 so no you're not
going to have the total to pay this debt
off and a 529 to Morgan look into this
but if it's been open longer than 15
years which it has you can roll it over
to a Roth IRA up to $35,000 so the
majority of this can be rolled over to
retirement which would do you way better
than cashing it out and having to pay
taxes and the penalty and everything to
pay off this debt so you and your
husband um that's what I would ask her
to do and if she's a career woman she's
going to be like good for you because if
account's been open for longer than 15
years you can roll it over to a Roth IRA
so Morgan I would roll it over to a Roth
in your name it's been open longer than
15 years and so that's exactly what I do
I would not cash it out I think you
would lose I didn't even know it was an
option so thank you so much yeah the B
an
Administration fast it something great
happens out of Washington last year and
it's fantastic so yes you can actually
roll it over so I would talk to a
smartvestor pro if you go to Ramsey
solutions.com uh you can look up one in
your area but i y that's exactly what I
would do Morgan um and then another
option if that's what you and your
husband choose not to do you can also
with 529s roll them over to another
beneficiary so you can actually earmark
that money for your kids you can
actually split it up and have that for
their college too it's just it is money
that is it it's grown taxfree I mean
it's just there there's so much benefit
to leaving it in that account and
protecting it that I don't I wouldn't
want to touch it uh for debt I think you
and your husband can attack that debt so
thanks Morgan thanks for the call thanks
for all of you in the booth John great
hour always also with you always fun
hosting with you and thank you America
for listening remember to take control
of your money and create a life you love
[Music]
n